jean lassalle bonjour je vous
interviewons et nous allons vous
interrogez pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view on aurait aimé
avoir un petit peu votre opinion sur la
situation française tant économique que
sociale que tout un tas de choses on va
commencer par la situation sociale vous
revenez d'un tour de france d'environ
6000 km c'est ça allait marcher pendant
six mille kilomètres juste avant vous
avez fait une petite grève de la faim
histoire de d'asseoir vos opinions et de
faire comprendre que vous étiez
quelqu'un de déterminé et jamais charte
est un peu vous avez chanté un petit peu
qu'est ce que vous nous faites remonter
comme information bout de 6000 km autour
de la france dans la france avec les
maires avec les habitants de la france
qu'est-ce qui est ce que les français
vous vous ou faire monter j'ai trouvé un
pays qui a peur et qu'il a plus
confiance à réel même personne et voyez
j'ai même le sentiment que ça s'est
aggravé depuis que j'ai fait ce tour de
france
pourquoi parce que après la crise
économique qu'ils ont senti centre
savoir d'où elles venaient mais
j'imagine que ça vient d'un changement
demande lequel notre pays n'a pas su
s'adapter et avec la crise sociale dans
le palier il est meurtri et maintenant
c'est une crise humaine c'est-à-dire une
relation crise la relation entre un
drame qui les met dans un état dans le
meilleur des cas de révolte
ce tarif est à la révolte oui dans
certains cas je dirais dans les régions
chez les interpréter comme ça le très
vieille
deux provinces voyez par exemple la
bourgogne l'armagnac safa étonnant
qu'ils étaient un peu constitutifs de la
france je dois cinq ans et dans le
sud-ouest d'une manière pas tout le sud
ouest
qu'est ce que les gens vous ont eu
davantage les gens disent d'avoir il
faut c'est très lent je devrais dire il
faut faire très attention
je n'aborde est jamais personne qui ne
le regardait pas ne permettez pas
d'aller à quelque sorte le chiot les
voyez je ne mets à prix jeunes talents
de gens qui venaient spontanément vers
moi que je n'arrivais même pas à faire
face à cette heure pour sortir de
valenciennes un lundi matin
donc ça vous donne une idée des gens que
je fais donc qu'est-ce qui vous font
remonter alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire
remonter
c'est d'abord au bout des tests on
déteste la classe politique on déteste
les politiques unis on les déteste
jusqu'à quel point pour certains sites
est en vous et c'est de la haine et très
vite
c est ce que vous vous rendez compte
dans quels états unis le pays sans qu'il
y ait ou que nous ne l'ayons vu le
moindre débat feriez plus débattre à
l'assemblée
beaucoup m'ont dit ça ça m'a étonné
d'une manière télévisés et que vous
entendez battier et ensuite c'est mais
nous vient cette [__] de lettres où
les plus endettés qu'au lendemain de la
guerre on paye notre lampe est même plus
qu'on doit on paye des montagnes
d'intérêts d'emprunt qui est paraît-il
de l'argent qui n'existe pas et l'europe
nous avons cru que vous construisiez
l'espace le plus avancé du monde grâce à
nos acquis sociaux humains sommes des
humanistes sont payés par des flots de
sang
le rêve d'un continent le plus vieux
apaisé et vivant en bonne harmonie et
vous en avez fait la plateforme la plus
avancée de la finance mondiale voilà en
gros ce qui met dit qu'est ce que
l'europe aujourd'hui où nous amener vous
vous avez senti les français traille
ah oui et douloureusement
ce qui m'a frappé c'est d'entendre cela
de notre âme dans le nord de la france
et l'est j'ai fait je ne sais combien de
mariages pour citer un exemple dans
cette bonne vieille ville de lille je l'
ai connu pour eux européenne je pense
qu'il n'y avait pas un seul anti
européenne l'histoire est là et j'avais
du mal à trouver quelqu'un qui ne
demandent pas l'europe
alors après tout ça suit vous parler de
social mais là ce que vous pensez qu'on
est à la veille de la nuit du 4 août
c'est du 4 août
est-ce qu on n'est pas à 1787 qu'on
n'est pas en 1913 d'une autre forme
ce n'est pas vous en avez parlé de la
1936 à cette règle 1935 en espagne vous
en avez parlé avec vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale de cette révolte
qui gronde dans les campagnes françaises
et j'ai été tellement impressionné
d'ailleurs après avoir j'ai commencé par
le nord et l'est de la france
j'étais très impressionné je suis arrivé
à l'alsace que j'ai décidé d'interrompre
pour mon tour de france de l'an à paris
n'est pas prévu pour rendre compte de ce
que j'entendais au président de
l'assemblée nationale et au président de
la république qui l'ont été le président
n'a pas pu le recevoir
président de l'assemblée a reçu mais
j'étais reçu qu'un conseiller une
conseillère du président la république
qui m'a dit on ne pas être surprise le
président de l'assemblée nationale ont
plus jolie mais moi je comprends c'est
la crise mais est-ce que nous avons
gardé aujourd'hui des moyens de suivre
l'évolution de la france j'ai le
sentiment qu'à tout moment il peut y
avoir un accident majeur pour une raison
ou pour une autre
ce qu'on a les moyens d'être enseignée
parce que j'ai vu et ça me savoir j'ai
décrit l'épisode importante que j'allais
vivre
cinq mois plus tard des patrons qui me
disait si des ouvriers descendre dans la
rue on va avec eux au pays de la lutte
des classes sur un taux d'is à des
syndicalistes plus remonté que des
coucous des femmes des mères de famille
des chômeurs toutes sortes de
d'hommes et de femmes que l'on croise
habituellement et monte il dit on sera
informée si ça pète quelque part par les
réseaux sociaux nous suivons les réseaux
sociaux et on y va vous aider mais vous
les avez senti on va dire prendre
position sur les réseaux sociaux est ce
que pour vous c'est une nouvelle façon
que les gens ont trouvé de se coaliser
autour d'une vraie démocratie
participative et est-ce que vous pensez
que l'internet procure cet espace
d'échangé et de débat alors si j'ai bien
compris les explications qui m'était
donné nos compatriotes ne ne l'analyse
pas encore d'une manière aussi
structurer une structure mais ils le
voient comme un moyen de se mobiliser et
de se retrouver et de peser soul dans un
débat dont ils se sentent complètement
exclue et sans aucune force ils disent
grâce au réseau par contre nous savons
maintenant que s'il y a quelque chose de
fort qui se dessine quelque part nous
saurons et nous pourrons par ce biais là
n'ont mobilisé comme nous ne pourrions
jamais le faire donc j'ouvre une petite
parenthèse concernant les réseaux
vous avez voté contre la loi de 2 sur le
renseignement
quelles étaient vos motivations
l'absence de confiance dans le
fonctionnement et c'est très grave parce
que je suis député je n'oublie pas un
seul instant est pour moi c'est une
charge qu'elle je suis très attaché
jamais arrivé pendant toute ma jeunesse
toute ma vie mon enfance je n'ai pas
confiance dans le fonctionnement actuel
de l'êta est gelée déclaré à plusieurs
reprises la scène nationale faisait
quelque chose j'ai plus confiance parce
que je me demande si nous avons encore
un conseil constitutionnel et si oui à
quoi il sert je mets très grave en cause
du conseil d'état parce que quand je
vois que pour la réforme des territoires
qui n'a pas été du tout préparé sur le
terrain n'a pas été fait avec le peuple
de france françois mitterrand lorsqu'il
a fait la sienne us à 82 l'avait annoncé
et a dit si je suis élu je ferai cette
réforme tout de suite
il avait aussi annoncé c'était pas très
populaire la fin de la peine de mort il
a fait les deux mais tout de suite
maintenant qu'est ce que vous voulez
reprise arrive d'abord il faut qu'ils
commencent par charge et de femmes
pendant l'été et ensuite on démarre sur
le dossier sociétaux et ensuite tout
d'un coup on se trouve en train de
parler des conseils généraux et des
conseils régionaux que l'on construit un
jour que le déconstruire lendemain des
régions à perte de vue et la disparition
des communes ce qui choque et qui touche
tous les français
eh bien le conseil d'état n'a rien
trouvé à redire cela j'ai payés sur les
fonds propres avec le nanny 10000 euros
une avocate qui est le droit d'ester
conseil d'état et je lui ai donné deux
les arguments qui était de deux ordres
le premier c'est que depuis clovis dans
notre pays
c'était institué une relation quasi
charnel entre l'homme et le territoire
ce qui fait qu'on a un territoire encore
entretenu comme du papier à musique et
la deuxième c'est la république
voulue par la constituante c'est le
premier alinéa égalité pour tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
et pour la première fois on allait
porter atteinte à ces deux notions qui
font iphone dans notre dacia c'est à
dire cette relation entre l'homme et le
territoire lorsque jeune homme en 1918
ou 240 et est appelée sur le front on ne
demandait pas comme il y avait un
habitant dans son village ou dans sa
ville à lui demander d'aller servir
jamais en france nous avions décidé de
2,2 de délire
nos représentants uniquement sur le
nombre de leurs ses lecteurs on tient
compte aussi de notre territoire et de
notre patrimoine est l'autre élément qui
a heurter profondément les français
c'est qu'il n'ya plus égalité de chasse
sur le territoire français parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous avez relu tous
les services publics
vous n'avez plus quelqu'un qui peut vous
conseiller vous aider au nom de l'état
voulue par le peuple et que vous avez
des étudiants pourront pas revenir sur
la loi renseignement pourquoi cette
opposition à le louer renseignement
alors donc comme je le disais reste déjà
ces deux structures
c2c pas de structure ces deux grands
corps de l'état ne faisait problème
et puis j'observe que depuis un certain
nombre d'années
il ya trop de pauvreté entre la haute
fonction de ta et des députés des
sénateurs et les membres du gouvernement
certains continuent à avoir les deux
c'est à dire ils peuvent être député 6
ans henry 5 6 à l'ump ou au ps wire dans
un parti si possible qui fait élire et
il reste au conseil d'état où il reste à
la cour des comptes où ils peuvent
d'ailleurs continué à recevoir un
appartement qui n'est pas négligeable
comment voulez vous dans ces
conditions-là d'abord connaît leur
représentativité du peuple tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
les particuliers en plus ouvrier il y en
a pas je dois être un des rares paysans
et s'étonnait des membres mon avis
qu'ils avaient été requis pour moi très
important mais sur leur enseignement
lui-même il suffit d'avoir sur soi
portable pour qu'on sache tout sur vous
on se défend tout sur vous mais je suis
élu depuis 39 ans maintenant j'ai vu
l'évolution et je sais qu'aujourd'hui
cela arrive vous cherchez bien vous
trouve à peu près sûr tous les domaines
qu'on veut mais se servir d'une cause
aussi forte et qui a si fortement
d'appeler nos compatriotes que les
attentats du 11 janvier pour dire on va
donner des moyens exceptionnels à nos
services secrets et le faire sans aucune
étude d'impact préalable pour savoir de
quelle manière on y parvenaient est-ce
que cela permettait de faire et quel
était le contrôle qu'elle était l'unité
qui allait procéder quand moi ça m'a
fait peur et alors quand je suis un
petit peu plus à la lecture et que
j'effectue ma vue gav est pas d'étude
d'impact que c'était une loi uniquement
conçu par l'émotion légitime que cela
m'étonne c'est que ça avait occasionné
il y avait de quoi
samedi à 4 5 millions de français qui
descend ça fera rue c'est beau est-ce
que vous avez vu dans ce texte de loin
une partie réservée aux sanctions en cas
d'abus alors c'est beaucoup plus c'est
là qu'est le problème à mon avis c'est
que justement ce n'est pas codifié comme
tout mais d'après ce que j'en ai compris
comme ces codifié pour d'autres aspects
pour d'autres délits
on sait que si vous commettez violent si
vous commettez ça dépend des
circonstances meurtre si vous ou même
une peine de code de la route
on s'est quand même bien encore d'une
certaine manière tandis que là c'est
beaucoup plus flou donc ceux de ce texte
là ne prévoit pas de sanctions oui en
même temps il
il rappelle pratiquement tous les
articles que ceux qui détiennent des
informations qui ne donnerait pas
pourrait faire l'objet de poursuites
lourdes mais je manifeste
je ne parlais pas au niveau de jeu par
le haut niveau de ceux qui emploient des
techniques d'interception en cas de
bavure ou en cas d'abus le texte ne
présente pas de sanctionner
j'ai une question à vous poser qui est
un petit peu parallèle et connexes à ce
sujet là est ce qu'il pensait que la
france s'est remis en question par
rapport à sa politique étrangère et ne
s'est pas dit notre politique étrangère
a généré des névroses
dans le camp d'en face est ce qu'on en
fasse avec cette conduite névrotique à
générer du terrorisme est-ce que vous
avez vu ça à l'assemblée nationale c'est
à dire une remise en cause de la
politique étrangère française et des
déviances que la politique étrangère
française a pu conduire sur notre propre
territoire
maintenant hélas non je dois dire hélas
parce que c'est très dommageable que
c'était une très importante par contre
j'ai vu chez notre compatriote monter
l'inquiétude de 20,7
non
révision de nos politiques
internationales alors là sur internet on
sait de la crise en libye
je pense que notre responsabilité est
très lourde dans cette affaire mais pas
car les villes je pense qu'un syrie en
irak
on a heureusement évité le pire à
n'intervenant pas directement mais je
crois que dans toute une partie du monde
aussi sensible il ne fallait pas être
prophète c'est le goût de le dire pour
voir le danger qu'il y avait
potentiellement avec l'immensité des
richesses qui ont cours la montagne des
changes qui ont dû à la crise une
seconde me chercher dans ces et
l'absence de politique bien posé le fait
d'aller intervenir là dedans comme un
éléphant dans un univers de porcelaine
il fallait pas être exemplaire pour
savoir que ça allait connaître des
dégâts et on a mis en place d'une
certaine manière nous mêmes aujourd'hui
ceux qui se comportent comme vous le
savez notamment en iran mais qui vivent
en iran qu'est ce qu'on a mis en place
en iran en irak
on a mené en irak en iran damas et sa
volonté de l'année tant d'années
cependant le chien sera du chat et puis
de l'ayatollah après revenir de khomeiny
je pense comme un bon pas c'est que au
fond ça l'espace est plutôt bien qu'on
allait trouver un contexte que régime
avec basé sur
la religion ça la correction que la
porte et nous l'avions pourtant payé
très cher dans notre histoire la laïcité
sentiment de laïcité pourrait poser des
problèmes on pourra revenir sur
l'historicité de la crise iranienne et
de jeu passionnantes entendu chanter
quand même engagé en mairie pendant
votre question et est engagé en syrie
parce que là j'en ai payé
non non ça n'a rien on peut être d'un
cran
nos soldats d'abord oui déjà mais là il
ya beaucoup de questions se posent et
ainsi d'avoir scellé population qui n'y
sommes pour rien si c'est sur ces pays
là et qui demande à peu près une seule
chose c'est qu'on me foute la paix voilà
et quand même ce n'était pas une demande
quand même excessive
deuxièmement comme toujours lorsque
notre pays ne sait pas où il est nos
dirigeants font des promesses
inconsidérées
alors bien sûr ils ne peuvent pas de
tenir et comme toujours
donc qu'ils aient souvent le cas hélas
avec des socialistes on se lance dans
des gaines je vous rassure
à droite aussi oui je suis pas rassuré
n'empêche mais mais c'est comme si tu
boiras socialistes font parler les
pianistes actuels
voilà donc se lancer dans des guerres
sans aussi comprendre toutes les
subtilités
alors bien sûr nous sommes un peu plus
subtil que les américains mais ça c'est
pas très difficile mais on a perdu alors
que nous avons à mon avis à mes yeux
la meilleure les plus assidus monde nous
la laissons choir comme le son choix
d'ailleurs nos ambassades des lieux de
savoirs de renseignements utiles des
changes mais manière humaine et surtout
contrôlable
donc à partir de ce moment là on ne sait
plus où on va c'est la course la fuite
en avant sans compter que moi là je
passe je peux poser la question
indiscrète mais je suis gamin religieux
imposés parfois la question de savoir
par quelle arme ont été tués non soldats
ceux du bleu-blanc-rouge et kieran vous
pensez que ces armes là son passé déjà
dans des mains de français s'y disent
qu'on a pas été construite chez nous et
je demande de même est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui se permettre de vendre tous
ses rafales bmi certes l'egypte mais est
passé à deux doigts de la
correctionnelle il ya deux ans et je
n'ai nous avait parlé vous avez parlé du
commerce des armes vous avez parlé des
états unis qu'est ce que vous pensez de
la position de vladimir poutine
par rapport à la liste noire dont je
suis mes souvenirs sont monde de députés
sont inscrits sur cette liste noire
je suis pas suffisamment recours impôts
pour vous répondre honnêtement je ne
vais péter français je sais pas si vous
avez si vous aviez une question
d'imposer vladimir poutine ce serait
laquelle
je lui demanderais si c'est vraiment du
même où il va je lui dirai je pense que
nous avons été très maladroit non
occidentaux suffit dire dans la
politique que nous avons conduits à ton
égard depuis une dizaine d'années n'a
pas envoyé beaucoup signaux positifs à
l'égard d'un pays qui sortait de 70
années de totalitarisme et qui s'est
chargé qui a perdu quand même 20
millions de ses concitoyens pour
délivrer de la menace fasciste nazi au
minimum 50 et ceux de staline hélas ce
qu'il faut changeons de sujet on va
parler de chômage des marchés financiers
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
le chômage déjà ce qu'est ce que vous
chiffres sont à jour non charge tous les
jours comment voulez vous je suis tous
les jours c'est à dire que la
température augmente et on change de
thermomètre on casse le thermomètre vous
vous passerez plus le terme à troll mais
car je suis à l'assemblée quand même en
train depuis pratiquement une quinzaine
d'années je suis incapable de dire cela
qu'il pensait qu'elle gouvernement selon
les indices ' de calcul comme il ya deux
chemins je crois que il y en a 5
millions 5 millions et demi et je ne
parle pas de ce que j'ai rencontré le
succès rencontré beaucoup qui ne le
sommes pas parce qu'ils ont décroché un
beau de contrats à durée très déterminée
ce qui les sort de la liste mais ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui qui sont ailleurs
pour exactement et arrière hélas sans
avenir qui se voient eux mêmes sans
avenir et qu'il faudrait travailler
donc moi je ne serais pas étonné que
nous soyons nous ne soyons pas très loin
pour un pays de cendrillon de l'état des
10 millions de chômeurs de chômeurs ou
de personnes qui dansaient un travail
régulier et d'institutions sûr de
retrouver le lendemain pour être précis
vos préconisations pour retrouver un peu
plus d'emplois en france me semble que
c'est assez ça au moins ne devrait pas
trop hésité
la france est belle et les traditions la
france s'est développée fond c'est quand
même un pays d'innovation
oui et pas de n'importe quelle
innovation nous avons quand même les
innovations nous on joue quand même il
faut pas faire les cocoricos toutes les
lignes mais de là à se diminuer tous les
jours on va même jusqu'à réduire la
taille de la france surtout vers la fin
de plus petites
ça me deuxième façade maritime du monde
avec nos amis et bien on est toujours
bel outil mais on nous avons abandonné
l'industrie l'industrie que je sache
nous étions très performant et
innovateur a soudainement qui devenait
l'industrie automobile pour ne citer
qu'un seul exemple je suis passé à
sochaux j'ai vu des hommes qui pleure et
de rage et c'était pas de sable aux
orris était désuet s'ingénièrent
hautement qualifiés
ils disaient nous avons été trahis mais
pas maintenant nous sommes trahis depuis
15 ans maintenant on nous offre le choix
de devenir chinois ou l'allemand
s'imaginait peugeot voilà pour citer un
exemple
l'apts les pme les artisans lui gagnait
de l'argent il ya dix ans un plombier on
lisait et ne va jamais moi j'étais
copain qui était plombier ya dix ans
n'était pas plein
aujourd'hui il se demande tous les jours
si on bat tony qu'il est financièrement
le lendemain matin
pourquoi parce que là aussi baisse de
commandes et le commande tout simplement
dans le construction dans la
construction donc on a fait plaisir aux
préconisations pour l'agriculture
ce qui est terrible dans un des premiers
conseils ventes sont tout autant de mal
que vous parce que encore un élément qui
échappe totalement à tout contrôle
en tout contre de quelques citoyens ce
qu'ils font c'est le taffetas taffetas
je connais moins six accords désaccord
transatlantique la wii ah oui oui ah je
pensais pas quand même été réduit à que
la france et la communauté européenne
avec tout ce dont nous savons tous ce
que nous avons dit à nos concitoyens
cela nous les ont convaincus était
capable de s'abaisser à ce niveau là
c'est à dire un accord directement avec
les états unis qui pourraient être
contrôlés
vous savez fait que la france puisse se
faire attaquer par philip morris parce
que philip morris trouve que les
pratiques sanitaires de protection en
france s'ils sont pas d'accord ils
attaquent la france ça vous fait
scandaleux c'est des criminels il dut et
je peux vous dire que je connais
d'autres cigarettiers qui ont d'ailleurs
pignon sur rue
puisque il
alors fait qu on fait quoi lien les
attrape
on l'aimé on nous en rang d'oignons va
place de la bastille qui aurait qu on
récupère une vieille veuve pour
s'occuper de leur cas dans l'europe
sorte du citoyen que j'ai publié en 2011
avant les présidentielles
ce que j'espère il servir à quelque
chose j'avais suggéré que les pays les
plus avancés et pesant le plus en
demande depuis ce qu'on fait des gestes
de celui des génisses et met sa tribu
des cinq pays dominants plus l'un d'eux
le brésil je ne fais pas ça sur la chine
puisque c'est pas un emploi mais pour
qu'on se mettre d'accord sur les mesures
à prendre sur des trafics de cette
ampleur génère autant de malheurs et de
mort voilà je passe la france là peut
pas s'attaquer à elle même tout seul on
prend déjà il est arrivé quand même
qu'on prenne quelques décisions ensemble
ne serait-ce que celle de faire la paix
on pourrait prendre six journées on paie
à l'heure actuelle non qu'est ce que
vous a séduit
qu'est ce que vous pensez de du terme
guerre économique
oui d'yvias ce qu'elle veut dire même
les poteaux elle ne dit pas la mort
qu'elles partent d'abord la mort de la
conscience la mort d'une certaine idée
de l'humanité
la mort de la relation humaine et puis
cette souffrance que chacun porte en lui
aujourd'hui quel que soit d'ailleurs le
niveau se situe dans la société mais
surtout dans les catégories les plus
modestes
vous n'avez plus rien n'apparaît que
vous n'attendez plus rien et que vous
savez même pas ce que va devenir votre
fils est un bon c'est un bon vivier de
bombes humaines c'est ça ah oui et alors
là c'est pas qui est qui qui tient la
mèche vous comprenez qu'est ce que vous
pensez des marchés financiers et des
autorités de régulation des marchés
financiers bien c'est la fête je dirais
c'est la signature d'un long processus
qui nous a dépossédé nos les politiques
de tout pouvoir au nom du peuple voulait
positif vous êtes laissé un petit peu
dépossédé c'est un peu on a même des
concessions consenties non oui on a même
aidé nous avons fait de l'homme choix
d'un père le parti socialiste est parti
du centre ont fait le choix depuis une
trentaine d'années tant que nous savions
très bien que nous acceptions de ne plus
peser sur les orientations majeures la
terre politique et en france une affaire
est ce que c'est un forfaiture je pense
que c'est une très grande erreur de
jugement
little forfaiture oui certainement mais
je pense que c'est plus que ça c'est une
c'est une trahison de nos élites comme
nous avons trahi parce que je ne suis
pas pareil je suis pas une bâche volant
mais je suis dans la politique depuis
j'avais des visionnaires d'ouvrir enfin
il faut que je me reconnais pas
démissionné mais en tout cas c'est pour
ça que je me suis bien marché donc on a
décidé de ne plus peser politiquement
est paru sur le marché on a accepté de
croiser la spéculation je lis pas la
filasse parce que la finance est un
outil qui pourrait être utile mais la
spéculation qui permet de faire des
montagnes d'or et de détruire les états
avec la technocratie soviétique
la spéculation américaine si vous voulez
bien avec la technocratie soviétique au
pays des droits de l'homme
il fallait retirer la pompe notre assise
de l'école de chicago et on peut on peut
le dire comme ça aussi même donc je vous
fais avec ses marchés financiers si
demain je vous donne les clés de la
france qu'est ce que vous faites avec
les marchés financiers je pense d'abord
que vous pouvez parler donner des clés
de la face comme ça et moi je peux pas
non plus les preuves
je crois que ça pose une question
fondamentale c'est la manière dont nous
allons faire ou pas refaire de la
politique
est ce que nous sommes capables de
reconstruire à nouveau une attitude qui
soit capable de nous faire parler
ensemble de réconcilier des hommes de
ordinaire de tous les jours qu'ils n'ont
plus le sentiment d'être des citoyens
j'ai trouvé une institutrice alsace qui
me cherchais depuis une quinzaine de
jours j'ai tout vu il m'a dit avoir 72
ahmadi j'étais une hussards noirs de la
république passionnément
je le fais d'autant plus que hélas mes
deux frères avaient aidé malgré nos j'ai
appris passionnément à lire et compter à
écrire et maintenant monsieur le député
je ne sais plus qui je suis je ne sais
pas si je suis alsacienne
si je suis française ou si je suis
mondiale si je dépends du fmi ou si j'ai
des fans du président de la république
avec qui je suis et quand j'en parle à
mes deux fils qui ont 35 ans il me dit
tu m'écoutes mama que ça peut te faire
tout le monde s'en fout mais le pire
c'est quand j'en parle à mes petits fils
que j'adore ils ont 19 et 20 ans ils le
disent et que mamie qui ça peut te
[__]
on aime beaucoup mais au moins de tout
le monde de dieu qui nous intéresse pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec nous alors je te
casse par l'ate intéressant mais ce
député ce que vous pouvez me dire qui je
suis et rien qu'un dans cette
intervention d'une femme passionnée de
notre pays
d'une femme passionnée règne française
qui connaît le kite à vivre sa liste de
notre pays qui sait que bien entendu
nous avons été minable parfois quand
nous n'étions pas bien diriger dit qu'on
dit mais que nous avons été aussi
magnifique assad à d'autres moments et
que nous sommes nous et nous avons été
détectée choisi par l'humanité comme
ayant une parole universaliste sur une
lame d'indépendance et de liberté
je reviens je reviens à ma question si
demain vous avez les clés de la france
par un grand tour de magie
qu'est ce que vous faites avec le
système financier déjà est-ce que vous
restez dans l'euro est ce que vous vous
restez dans l'europe
qu'est ce qui vous fait pour réguler les
marchés financiers alors d'avoir dès que
je le dise devenait très convaincante
pour ne pas penser à cela est à sa lame
de voix de voir si je suis en face de
vous je n'ai pas du tout envie mais je
commence peut-être par une campagne
électorale où je m'efforce de reprendre
langue avec le peuple
et puis de découvrir d'ouvrir ensemble
quelle est la véritable situation dans
notre pays sur les questions doivent
poser sur les questions de la dette sur
la question de l'absence sur l'exercice
euro l'euro l'europe et sur la question
de l'europe bien entendu et écouté
si moi je décide tout seul je tombe dans
le jeu si vous avez les français avec
vous et français nous écoutent les
français ont confiance en dsk se
considère que le peuple s'ouvrait doit
décider si le peuple ça la moindre des
choses
le dernier qu'on a fait les français ont
voté oui a voté contre
et nous nous avons très moyenne de nous
réunir les salariés pour dire oui au nom
de notre peuple
vous avez noté tous deux pensent at ça
nous coûte très cher aujourd'hui nous le
payons très cher
nous payons très cher cette affaire
jacques billant quelques-unes se la
péter brigger sûr mais en même temps
référendum ça ne veut rien dire du jour
au lendemain je pense que c'est un
processus qui n'a jamais lieu tout au
long de la construction européenne nous
ne nous sommes pas tenus informés de ce
que nous faisions et là hier nous
n'avons pas une courage de le faire nous
même nom les politiques élus par le
peuple
nous avons envoyé encore une fois des
hauts fonctionnaires mandaté comme le
maire qui enverrait son secrétaire de
mairie avec notre secrétaire de mairie
au chef-lieu de préfecture pendant dix
ans en dix ans près par mois le
département de demain où la commune de
demain
et moi je viens de vous vérifiez tous
les trois ans et on fera des
déclarations publiques voilà comment
fonctionne donc bien entendu il ya une
grande grande travail de mise à niveau
qui doit être entrepris et qui doit se
solder par un référendum
on a on a quelques minutes encore j'ai
vous poser une question je vais vous
lancez un mot et de but en blanc vous
allez me dire ce qui vous passe par la
tête
on essaye ainsi participative a bien sûr
oui en les faisant jouer leur rôle
qu'elle doit jouer c'est à dire il veut
pas y avoir dans des marques de
démocratie sans participation
nous l'avons totalement oublié mais je
pense que nous savons maintenant
deux siècles et +22 république qui nous
a permis d'avoir aussi une démocratie de
représentation le seul problème c'est
qu'il faut être capable de porter un
mandat du peuple parce que ce n'est pas
un métier
ce n'est pas une carrière et de se
retirer sur des voitures des faits
passés sous condition d'être ans et je
vous dis si l'anecdote juste vous une
toute petite 1m dit vous les politiques
c'est terrible que nous parle comme ça
qu'un non politique
vous êtes une espèce dont on ne se
débarrasse jamais on a le bonheur de
nous battre aux législatives du mois de
mai là le bonheur de votre vie sénateurs
mois de septembre
parfois maire de la commune le mois de
mars ici car ce n'est pas président du
conseil général et du conseil régional
vous voyez que ya quelque chose qui me
paraît aller dans cette affaire là et
que israël est est ce que c'est une qu
est ce que c'est une caisse de parasites
de parasites nan parce que tu te serves
as jeu parce que l'immense majorité
d'entre nous aurons le souci de bien
faire
par contre c'est une catégorie qui s'est
coupé
nous nous sommes coupés du peuple et que
le peuple est un mal à quelque sorte
avec lequel il faut s'accommoder au
mieux pour faire passer nos idées
2 si je vous dis l'air va changer jeudi
barack obama l'a fait ce qu'il a pu mais
il a montré les limites d'un président
des états unis
il pèse pas lourd si je vous dis
vladimir poutine
hamon avait il montre les possibilités
de chefs d'état qui apprend à composer
avec un peuple qui n'est plus [__] et
qui doit à la fois gérer si ça parle
avec les autres si je vous dit jeannette
jelen tchad et jelen qui est la
présidente de la fed la banque centrale
américaine
je parle ou affinités a priori parce que
cette action son prédécesseur ben ben
bernanke n'ont pas davantage parce que
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'affinités avec
des organisations et les lilas ces
organisations dans le jeu ne se
prenaient à l'invention on est une
chaîne youtube
certes sur internet mais on a des
contacts un peu dans la vraie vie ici
vous parler d'organisation si je vous
dis le club bilderberg ce à quoi ça vous
fait penser fils et moi je si je vous
dis la commission trilatérale
s'il vient il alors la fonction d'un
latéral j'ai entendu ça on a eu ni à mon
avis rien qui vaille pas c'est encore le
culte du secret ce le culte de sacha à
aux plus petits des niveaux - nombre
possible qui décide
hollande dos de la politique
tenez si vous avez un choix à faire
entre ces deux phrases assez foule
aveugle ou à ces politiques qu'il en
crève les yeux
à ces foules aveugle ou à ces politiques
qu'ils en crèvent les yeux assez folle
aveugle à l'âge mais assez fou de la
vague est ce que les gens sont aveugles
ou est ce que sont les politiques et
leurs crève les yeux
c'est parce que c'est el-assad parce que
nous pourrions nous rendre compte il
faut pas non plus que je les câbles les
décideurs ou ceux qui croient décidé
aujourd'hui parce qu'enfin de décidant
plus rien je crois aussi parce que j'ai
posé un certain nombre d'actes qu' il y
a aussi beaucoup hélas de nos
concitoyens qui veut faire encore faire
ça ou ça et c'est assez vrai aussi parmi
vos collègues médias de supporter région
et tous et des la presse écrite à ce
sujet quand même posé des actes qui
étaient des actes forts sur lequel
j'étais très médiatisée
j'ai terminé ma grève de la faim devant
sans télévision internationales et pas
des moindres sur ça me dirait qu'à la
télévision
vous savez dans quel contexte j'ai
terminé mon tour de france est bien de
moi après j'avais disparu des radars
j'ai écrit un livre bien surtout monde
écrit un livre après l'aveu proposer un
acte comme celui là est bien qu'est-ce
que j'ai eu des monges entier pour lui
de
des principaux acteurs de laurent
ruquier 2 de l'us ces intellectuels
médiatiques
voilà qui vont diront peut-être quand
invitera l'approchait mais c'est
difficile de parler de ton livre dans
l'état actuel l'an prochain j'ai des
auteurs vous voulez donc vous savez il
ya peut-être sont peut-être plus
nombreux à être dans l'erreur
ce que je crains c'est que cet
aveuglement peu collectif nous
conduisent à commettre ce que noah y n
ont pas pu éviter parce que nous sommes
dans une phase qui ressemble étrangement
vous me demandiez tout à l'heure quelle
année nous étions mais je ne sais pas
moi si on n'est pas dans une situation
qui ressemble étrangement au moment où
magellan et christophe colomb découvre
des années des amériques et où les
montagnes d'or qui les amène déstabilise
des états les royaumes de l'époque
seulement le facteur temps est plus là
des révolutions interviennent [__] en
tout cas certaine obtenu la possibilité
d'organiser des disettes les ruines les
misères et les guerres qu'il fallait
lorsqu'un 1900 les mails vous pensez que
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
organisé le 10 aides financières cette
austérité cette novlangue cette
novlangue distillé à nos concitoyens
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
organiser le sait c'est vrai bien sûr en
tout cas ce n'est pas il n'y a pas le
moindre début de combat qui est mené
pour y mettre un terme
pas plus qu'il y en avait en 1900
lorsqu'on a vu les trains s'étiraient à
perte de vue jusqu'au fond des amériques
jusqu'au fans d europe
ces insectes métallisé que l'on venait
de construire et ce liquide de couleur
indéfinissable dont on passer l'ensemble
du sous sol recouvert et bien les mêmes
ont fait le même calcul que vous pensez
les gîtes de pouvoir que ça engendrerait
ducasse affrontements et les plus gros
investissements les plus grandes
spéculations jamais vu pour tuer des
hommes et nous sommes dans un troisième
mouvement de mondialisation qui est un
mouvement
dus en grande partie par les moyens de
communication n'avons jamais eu autant
de moyens de communication d'aujourd'hui
et nous avons aussi peu parlé ensemble
entre nous et je pense que nous courant
les mêmes risques à 1900 cela a débouché
qu'est ce qu'on fait sur les deux
tragédies et ce qu'on fait jean lassalle
qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien fait une
révolte on fait une révolution commence
à s'organiser on peut plus organiser
parce qu'ils vont être surveillés ou un
cinéma comme le terroriste on fait
comment s'organise on commence à
attraper nos députés au feu rouge on
fait quoi non moi je suis je suis et de
chasseurs si ma part si je me sens qu'un
matelas
les français aussi je ressens bah oui là
mais le français les mais il faut qu'ils
soient guidés aussi parce que il faut
quand même pas oublier que la base était
quand même de fyfe collaborateurs pas
menacer son soutien donc il faut quand
même pas
mais à côté de ça nous arrange et des
fulgurances ceux qui ont encore remarqué
le monde entier et nous avons permis et
des dons elle figure a fait une grande
fusion
je peins je vais vous poser leurs
questions et c'est bien la question est
les classiques sur notre chaîne youtube
c'est donner un conseil aux jeunes
générations
donc vous avez l'opportunité de laisser
une bouteille à la mer sur les réseaux
sur internet cette vidéo sera
pratiquement immortel laisser un conseil
aux jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer prenez votre vie à bras le corps
aujourd'hui vous êtes viré la jeunesse
vous avez la phase avec vos n'est pas
forcément le savoir mais il vient moi
j'étais maire a 21 ans et du roman de se
demander qu'est ce que je
je suis toujours 39 ans après n'attendez
pas que pour l'instant on puisse vous
dire ce qu'il convient de faire nous ne
le savons pas nous mêmes par contre si
vous vous mettez en route
vous allez nous redonner le goût et on
peut refaire quelque chose qui n'est
peut être positif dans nos pays mais qui
a été fait dans notre jeu peut pas
oublier que gandhi a ouvert la route du
sel est fichue les anglais qui n'avaient
aucune envie de quitter leur sens d'une
goutte de sang ont pratiquement ne pas
oublier que dans un autre pays
terrifiant un homme a passé 31 ans en
prison ça qu'on s'ajuste pourquoi alors
bien sûr ce qu'il a fait un peu mieux
grâce parce que le bonheur de l'ue mais
ne dure jamais très longtemps mais on
peut connaître au lieu du fracas que mes
paroles pourrait laisser son entame une
période de lumière la plus grave de
réserve dont nous disposons notamment
chez les jeunes c'est l'intelligence
c'est ça donne en observons le moins
c'est aussi la sagesse chez nos seniors
qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'enseignant dès
qu'ils avaient des coûts même si l'ombre
fini terminé ils sortent du cadre alors
que si on leur porter d'attention qu'on
devrait leur portée il s'intéresserait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des moyens de
communication tels que les vôtres la
matière grise qu'il faut acquérir dos à
servir comment ne pas s'intéresser
beaucoup plus à ces moyens de
communication comment s'est adressé à
l'imprimerie à l'autre moment au
telegraph
d'autres moments ce que nous savons
beaucoup de possibilités le tout c'est 2
d'arriver à convaincre et je pense que
ça dans le cadre émotionnel parce que la
politique c'est aussi de l'émotion que
confèrent les campagnes électorales
qu'il faut reprendre langue sur tout ça
en tout cas moi je me suis mis out je
reprends pas grand chose me suis tout de
même encore un député dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
j'ai posé des actes je regarde ce que ça
donne il faut convenir pas grand chose
pour l'instant mais c'est pire que lui
nierait somni
je termine là si vous permettez ému a
sonné ce terrible dire j'ai 60 ans et
les quatre fils de député que je laisse
aujourd'hui au moins de chances de
réussir leur vie que les quatre fils de
berger que mon père a laissé seulement
demande de partir et partir comme ça ça
me donne tellement mal au ventre je peux
pas dormir la nuit je me réveille c'est
pour ça que j'ai marché et c'est pour ça
que j'ai envie de continuer à réfléchir
à apporter ma volonté
ma fureur de vivre d'une certaine
manière mais mon bonheur du printemps la
joie d'être humain le plaisir d'être de
sainte-terre le plaisir d'être vigilants
pour que ça se fasse d'une manière
différente pour la première fois en
france le choix 5 merci là c'est à vous
une